there's a there's a heading and it's a
huge mouthful to understand it
understand what the head to means that's
always a good thing to start with let's
just tease this apart a little bit
we'll start with quadratic equations
you've met quadratic equations before
okay
quadratic is when you're squaring
something right by the way if you ever
wondered why is it called a quadratic
think of like a quadrangle a corn Dragon
will be usually the square in shape
all right angular so for instance this
is a quadratic we've seen this one
before
I've seen it to death that's quadratic
this is a quadratic equation right you
see what I added and what makes an
equation it's an equation because got an
equal slope okay now when you go to
these words up here okay solving solving
means tell me what values would make is
true right how would we do this one by
the way we do it yeah good I'm thinking
a pair of numbers that will multiply to
6 and add to 5 and the reason why I'm
doing that is because I would factorize
right so I have these two factors here
of course the numbers are 2 & 3 okay but
what do I do with that okay so so
there's pair of numbers right you
multiply them and they get zero so one
or both of these numbers have to be zero
right if this is zero X plus 2 then X
should be negative 2 that would make X +
2 0 or alternatively the other one right
if X were negative 3 then X plus 3 would
be 0 okay because you chuck it in and
then just banish it away right so that's
what it means to solve
ok now let's get to this last part of
history from monic money like a monorail
or or a monocle just means one right so
it's referring to this number out the
fun this guy here okay it's a 1 because
the one I don't usually write it because
one times anything is just one of the
things right but there is really a one
hiding there
so if that's what Manik means what do
you think known what it means
it means if more than one right it could
be a two or three or a negative five or
some other value that's not one okay so
let me give you an example and we'll
solve it together that was one ik he's a
non Manik one for you okay
now we're just gonna take this one
example I'm gonna show you two ways to
solve it I like one way more than the
other and you'll see why in a second and
then leading up to next Tuesday you can
start I think it's exercise 1101 but
I'll show them alright so if he calls
method number one another because there
are lots of ways to do this in fact I'm
gonna show you two today and I'll show
you two more next week and again
sometimes the challenge is not just to
know the techniques but to know when to
use them he comes number one
see how I'm trying to get towards this
paired up thing here this factorized
form okay
the problem we're doing one of these is
not quite as simple just think of a
number that multiplies to ten and adds
tonight right like I did up here because
this pesky two out the front is making
things more complicated right so here's
one technique I can use that 9x in the
middle and once you break it up into two
parts one of which will factorize with
this and one of which will factorize
with that okay so I'm breaking it apart
right so for example and you'll see why
I picked these numbers innocently do you
agree that 9x is the same as 4 X + 5 X
is that okay that's one way I could
break it on it's not the only way I
could break it up but the reason why I
choose 4 & 5 is because now this becomes
a pair and this becomes a pair I can
factorize right um if for instance I
hadn't chosen 4 X + 5 X suppose I've
chosen 3 X + 6 X 3 X + 6 X ok this pair
and this pair what factorizes neatly
whereas here watch what happens first
pair what common factor can I take out
- I can take - and I can take an X so
I'm gonna write 2x out the front okay
once I take 2x are what do I get left
behind this and there's a - good X -
fantastic I've done the first pair when
I look at the second pair what factor
can I take out by the delightedly
and again this is why I chosen to my
numbers I got X plus 2 if you're chosen
your pairs well you get the same thing
happening twice right if you get
different things you can't really
progress to the next step just like I
factorize this I took out a 2x I'm gonna
factorize this now what's the cofactor
x+ I'm gonna expose to happening for
both of them right once I take that out
what am I left with 2x + 5 you see that
you see where my 2 xn + 5 come from 2x +
5 and now I'm in my magical factorized
form okay so I've got a here now I can
solve this thing right
what value of x will make this pot zero
what value X will make this part 0
there's something bit tricky up because
you've got this fractional this year but
I think you can convince yourself it's
-5 / - okay
that 2 will cancel there you'll be left
with minus 5 plus 5 equals 0 I'm done
and that was method 1 it's a good method
when it works okay but it's a little bit
like and you'll see when we do later
examples for your homework and next week
it's a little bit like counting on your
fingers and toes
okay so West Sun is 4 and he's just
trying to mask the numbers between 10
and 20 okay and he literally needs to
use his fingers and toes and if I asked
him to count can you count to 17 right
he will say he would go one to do dinner
and you'll end up on or end up on his
second foot on 17 right if I say now key
tell me what's 2 less than that he has
to start back at 1 and then go up to 15
he can't subtract - right so it works
but it's very very slow and of course we
don't need to do that anymore so let me
show you a better technique it works in
more examples
same question but I like this because
it's more powerful it'll works with
negative numbers in particular which
will have a look at the x-ray
remember how here what I wanted was a
pair of numbers something in something
which added to five right and I want a
pair of numbers something and something
that multiply to 6 do you remember that
ok I'm gonna do almost exactly the same
thing but I'm gonna take this 2 into
account right watch I want a pair of
numbers that adds to give me 9 just
slack before ok but now instead I one of
the paradigms that multiplies not to 10
but to 20 I'm gonna take that part this
2 times 10 so I don't point to you okay
now of course you can see here right the
reason why this is a great technique is
because it hijacks this skill we already
have the pair of numbers of course is 4
& 5 right 4 & 5 so here's what I'm gonna
do it's very similar to this slide with
one little difference I'm gonna write
plus 4 and plus 5 that's the two numbers
you told me right
but you've noticed I put a 2x in both
places instead of just an X this is a
way of solving a problem but it
introduces another one if I were to
expand this out like go in reverse
what's 2 makes times 2x because I've got
the twos happening twice the 2 is it
going to come together become a 4 and
then the answers are gonna come back
together get us an x squared so I'm a 4x
squared
I don't what 4x squared 2x squared so
I'm gonna make up for that I'm gonna
compensate by dividing by that number
okay
if for example I have 5 X square here 5
X 5 X divided by 5
now here's where the magic happens right
we find the values whole thing by 2 and
what are these brackets b / - I don't
care right it's the first one isn't it
okay this one's not so great because
it's got a an odd number in it that were
divided by 2 neatly but this one will
okay so I can divide everything in here
by 2 what am I gonna get X plus 2 just
like we got before you see that
equals zero okay now you can see two
things number one it is ever so slightly
quicker ever so slightly okay
secondly it uses this skill you already
have thirdly which I haven't revealed
yet but you'll see it's so much better
if one of these is a negative one of
these is a negative this process here
becomes fiendishly hard and
time-consuming just like counting to
seventeen on your toes okay so therefore
I prefer this method once you've got to
hear your answers are the same just like
before